okay so this actually happened I I
didn't I kept seeing this this thing
online about how somebody complained
that the Lord of the Rings is racist
against orcs and I saw that and I really
honestly thought that it must have
originated with the babylon b or
something like that but no it's real a
guy named Andrew Duncan on the geeks
Guide to the galaxy podcast really said
he really argued in all sincerity that
Tolkien was racist because he depicted
some creatures as being worse than
others and this has had it is these are
his words quote dire consequences for
society because of the racism that was
generated in that story against orcs
which you know he's not wrong I I read I
read Lord of the Rings myself when I was
in Middle School and from then on I
harbored this deep bigotry towards
undead goblins that have been mined out
of the earth by evil wizards and I never
really thought of it until now but I
really did hate them I did wanted
nothing to do with them I didn't want to
sit next to them and I've been like this
my whole life and it but now I finally
have a chance to confront that prejudice
and and repent of it so I appreciate
that all right we talked yesterday about
the the case of James James is the
six-year-old child in Texas at the
center of a custody dispute his mother
wants him to be a girl named Luna and
insists that he's transgender puts him
in dresses all that stuff but then when
he's with his dad
James just wants to be James and he
wants to be a boy and do boy things and
go by the name James he doesn't want it
what doesn't want to wear dresses now
his dad is trying to to rescue him from
all this madness and let him just be a
boy like he is and like he wants to be
but the mom is accusing the dad of child
abuse the mom who's tried to turn her
son into a girl is accusing the dad who
wants his son to just be his son of
child abuse for refusing to affirm
James's alleged transgender identity now
I already made my points about this case
and
I'm sure it wouldn't shock you you you
won't be shocked to learn that I side
with the dad very strongly
I think this child is being exploited
and abused by the people who are trying
to foist transgenderism transgenderism
on him not just as his mother but
apparently his therapist but there's one
other point about all this that I didn't
make yesterday and I think that needs to
be made so I want you to think about
this a lot of people on the left
especially the the militants and the
LGBTQ camp so especially the LGBT
activists they insist that children as
young as as James as James you know as
young as six years old he's six children
even as young as five or even three kids
really at any age they say possess the
knowledge and the foresight and the the
wisdom and the power to choose their own
gender so the left has no problem with
the idea of an elementary school boy
transitioning into a girl they say well
if that's what he chooses then it's okay
they have no problem even with kids
young kids taking drugs puberty blockers
hormones to essentially chemically
castrate themselves even if temporarily
in order to facilitate this this
transition they think that kids can
consent to that now this raises a very
important question I think if a child is
too young to consent to having sex how
is he at the same time old enough to
consent to changing his sex I mean the
consent laws are based on the correct
idea that that children do not have the
mental or physical capacity to really
fully consent to sexual activity they
just they they are not able to consent
to it because they don't have a full
concept of what it even is and because
they're young kids they also don't have
the power in
situation to to to consent to say no so
that's why we have the consent age where
it is that's why we say that kids can't
consent but if they don't have that
capacity how are they possibly able to
choose to transition if they can't
choose to have sex how can they choose
to transition how do they have if they
don't have the wisdom and the knowledge
and all of that and the maturity for one
of those things how do they have it for
the other so obviously there's a
contradiction here the people that are
pushing transgenderism on kids are also
at the same time by necessity pushing an
entirely different idea about consent
and about the mental capacities and the
maturity of children which is why I
believe the push the people that are
pushing transgenderism will soon enough
be pushing pedophilia the two things
kind of go hand in hand because in order
to to make their case that kids can make
this choice they have to tell us that
actually no kids have all the knowledge
and power and and maturity that they
need
so when pedophilia is normalized in our
culture and I think that it will be soon
enough
this is the vehicle by which it will
reach that state of normalization and
this is this is the reason why this is
one of the reasons why this issue really
matters this is why it's important
because what we're seeing here is an
attack on kids an attack on childhood
and it's not gonna stop with just this
it's not gonna stop with just the
transgender stuff nothing ever stops you
know you never get to a point especially
with the left when they're when they're
they never stop if you've noticed that
once they achieve one thing they get to
one landmark they're gonna want to go on
to the next that's what that's how it
always works so soon enough the people
that are saying that kids are old enough
to consent to changing their sex will
also be arguing that kids are old enough
to consent to having sex and this is not
some kind of like far-fetched scenario
okay but pedophilia has been
in the past and is now today in some
cultures considered normal ancient pagan
cultures had no problem with it it's a
relatively normal practice in some parts
of the world even today so it's by no
means impossible or even implausible
that we in our culture could slide back
into that state of things but there has
to be a catalyst for it there has to be
something that sparks the change and I
think this is it this is what will spark
it and so this is why we need to pay
attention okay a couple other things I
wanted to discuss there's a piece that's
been going viral over the last few days
it's been pushed out especially by the
feminist corners of the internet and it
originates from Glamour magazine's
website which is a website that I
personally check every day as I'm sure
you do as well and the article is titled
I'm a great cook now that I'm divorced
I'm never making dinner for a man again
and the pullquote right on it right
under the title says I stopped cooking
because I wanted to feel as unencumbered
as a man walking through the door with
the expectation that something had been
done for him the piece written by Liz
Lenz talks about the oppression that she
experienced in her marriage when she was
forced to cook all the time and this
seems to you know this seems to really
be resonating with with a lot of people
who are reading it so the article starts
like this it says when my marriage fell
apart I stopped cooking I gave my
children frozen chicken nuggets Pizza
quesadillas or their favorite cheese
sticks nuts fruit crackers veggies all
displayed on a hand-me-down china
platter now they eat like fancy ladies
as my first grader says piling her
little paper plate with nuts and grapes
I live off I live off of bagged salads
rotisserie chicken and whiskey that
makes two of us
I stop except for the salad part I
stopped cooking because I was tired but
kind of tired where your face vibrates
and your eyes throb too tired to care
what I put in my mouth and my children
then six and four only wanted to eat
gogurts and cheez-its anyway the person
who cared was my husband I had been
cooking for him
for 12 years when we first married and
moved to Iowa I couldn't find a job I
spent my days cooking I worked my way
through the joy of cooking mastering
pastry dough for beef wellington so on
and so forth she talks about all the
things that she made hoping that when he
came home my husband would sit down and
taste them and say thank you but he
doesn't say thank you and then it goes
on it's pretty lengthy talking about all
the things she cooked and then we get to
the climactic moments she says and then
one night as my daughter watched TV my
toddler screamed from the living room
and the water boiled to collecting steam
on the windows I broke I cut and chopped
and desperately looked at a recipe on my
phone my back burned with frustration my
feet ached from standing the steam
flushed my cheeks and I wondered at the
molecules that could escape from the
heat as I stood there spatula in hand
it's hard for me to understand when
cooking became more repression than
liberation more act of obligation than
act of creation but I knew it then this
thing that had sustained me now felt
like a prison and whose fault was it
it certainly wasn't all my husband's
fault after all had and I wanted to cook
hadn't I enjoyed it in the tangle of
performance and purpose in my quest to
make a home and love I had created
elaborate offerings which were consumed
and judged and yet afforded me no
redemption no grace no more than four
out of five stars
that night I dumped the water in the
sink toss the ingredients in the trash I
poured myself a glass of wine and threw
some frozen chicken nuggets on the
microwave when my husband came home we
were already eating that was the last
time I cooked for two years and then she
talks about how she would spend her days
I would wake up at 5:00 in the morning
and go work out then I'd come home get
the kids ready for school dropped them
off come back to the house and cry I was
supposed to be working but mostly I just
sat and stared at the Word document that
had become my daily journal and I wept
that I would try to nap in the guest
room until it was time to pick up the
kids from school so basically this is a
this is a I would say a tad dramatic
self pitying that's that's going on here
I mean she
paints it as if she's in some kind of
like POWs camp or something like that
when all she's doing is just making a
meal for her family but my act by my
back aches my feet were burning from
from cooking all day I mean yeah look I
you know fine it seems that she's upset
mainly about the perceived so if we
could put all the the drama aside and
everything like that and cooking is
supposed to be an act of redemption I
you know I don't even know what that
mean I don't think it's a boat it's not
supposed to act of redemption it's just
something that you do because people
need to eat in the house and so I don't
you know I don't think it needs to be
this great poetic moment every single
time you do it but it seems that she's
upset and I and I think there is there's
there are many different ways you could
go with this but there's also a point
here to be made about something that
seems to be common especially in my
generation and younger generations where
we kind of we don't like anything that's
eaten it's an obligation we don't think
that anything should be an obligation we
think that everything we do should have
this great deep purpose and we should
find deep fulfillment in everything that
we do she talks about no it shouldn't be
an obligation it should be an act of
creation
and so we want everything we do to be
this to be this creative expression of
our of our innermost being but that's
not that's not how life works and not
everything you do is going to be that
way in fact most of the things if you're
going to be a competent and mature
adults especially if you're gonna be a
parent and and and and you're gonna be
contributing member of a family most of
the things you do on a daily basis are
just kind of mundane tasks that need to
be done you know what I take the garbage
out I'm not asking myself what am I
getting out of this you know taking the
garbage out used to be this fulfilling
act of self affirmation but now I feel
like it's just a it's just a drudgery
all I'm doing is no I don't have that
crisis I just I just the garbage needs
to be taken out
I just take it out that's all not
everything has to be fulfilling you just
do it because it needs to be done and it
seems like people these days struggle
with this concept that there are things
you do there are a lot of things you do
just because they need to be done and
for no other reason and if you're gonna
stop doing things that need to be done
and only do the things that you find
fulfilling then you're gonna end up like
the writer of this piece you just spend
your days crying and napping because the
thing is there aren't that many
fulfilling things to do in a day if you
say to yourself I'm only gonna fill my
day with fulfilling things then it's
just you're just gonna end up on your
bed crying I guess which is what which
is what unfortunate having this woman
now it seems mainly that she's upset
about the perceived lack of appreciation
and gratitude on her husband's part and
listen gratitude is very important in a
marriage if somebody makes you a meal
you should say thank you you should
appreciate it it can be deadly in a
marriage if one or both spouses feel
that the other is not grateful doesn't
care doesn't appreciate but you know as
I'm reading this and I'm thinking about
how much it apparently resonates with
some women on the internet a lot of
women apparently I couldn't help but
notice something maybe you noticed the
same thing first of all she says that at
first she didn't have a job her husband
work to support the family she didn't
have a job then she alludes to a job
later on but so I guess she got a job
later but she says that she wouldn't do
her job and instead she would go to the
gym take a nap and then go pick the kids
up so it seems like from this it seems
like her husband was the primary person
in the family supporting everyone in
earning a paycheck that's what it would
seem like from how she presented it so I
have to wonder did she appreciate that
was she grateful so she wanted to thank
you for the meals that she prepared fair
enough and and she should get a
thank-you but did she ever thank him for
working
maybe she did but the way she tells the
story she paints her husband as this
oath who did nothing but eat did she
treat him that way during the marriage
did she treat him that way in spite of
all the work that he was doing to
sustain the family did she ever say
thank you to him when when she when he
got when he walked in the door from work
did she ever say thank you for the work
you did today
when when he brought home the paycheck
did she ever say thank you for that if
if she was expecting gratitude and
appreciation did she ever give it in
return as I said I don't know but you
have to wonder what his side of the
story would be and you wonder if he went
to work every day long hours supporting
his family unappreciated you wonder if
he felt that there was no gratitude for
his contributions you wonder if he
noticed the resentment from his wife
when he got home each day because
apparently you know eventually she
started to really hate the fact that she
had to cook a meal and you wonder if he
noticed that and he would walk into a
resentful spiteful wife you wonder you
know you wonder if how he felt when he
came home after a long day's work and as
she says his family was already eating
without him
could even be bothered to wait he walks
in he's been working hard all day and
his wife has you know got the feet
kicked up having some wine there are
they've already eaten without him you
wonder how he felt about that but here's
the thing if he was feeling just as fed
up as his wife if he was tired too
if his back was aching and he and his
knees hurt and all that stuff if he was
having all those same same feelings he
couldn't just stop working
you know she apparently decided to stop
contributing to the family at a certain
point and that's what she says she would
just go to the gym and and and you know
take a nap but that's what but but I
assume he couldn't do that someone had
to
the family he had to continue on and I
you know you have to wonder how he felt
about that you know there's a lot of
this kind of stuff online there are many
many articles that have been written
about the unappreciated waif many movies
have been made that deal with that theme
many TV shows have dealt with it this is
a common thing that you hear it says
emphasize that women need to be
appreciated and we and we see these
kinds of stories all the time about the
unappreciated wife and and that's you
know women do need to be appreciated in
a marriage that's that's definitely true
but that fact at least is generally
emphasized in our culture the reverse is
not emphasized hardly at all if it seems
that women are rarely encouraged to be
grateful for their husbands
that's this just not something that you
you see very often now fortunately I I
feel a lot of appreciation in my
marriage and I try to give appreciation
to I hope that I give it as much as I
should although I'm sure I could be
better at it than I am
but I do know for sure that there are a
lot of men who feel just like the writer
of this article feels and perhaps with
more justification than she had yet
their plight isn't taken as seriously
and if they complain they would probably
just be called lazy deadbeats and told
to just you know get their act together
and do what they needed to do I mean can
you imagine an article from a man
complaining that his wife never thanked
him when he got home from work each day
so so eventually he just stopped going
to work can you imagine that do you
think that article will be well-received
because I don't think it would be look
the point is gratitude and appreciation
are extremely important in a marriage in
both directions they they are absolutely
essential going both ways husband - wife
wife - husband the wife's job the the
mother's job is difficult there's no
question about that whether she works
outside of the home or whether she
doesn't it is difficult to be a mother
and to
be a wife no question but the man's job
the husband's job the father's job is
also difficult and if one of them is
home and the other is out working it's
wrong for the person who's out working
to treat the other like they don't do
anything all day and they don't
contribute to the family that's wrong
but it's also wrong in the other
direction it's wrong for the one who's
at home dealing with the kids and all
that stuff to treat the other person
like they're on vacation when they go to
work because work is not a vacation the
support of family is not a vacation it's
a difficult thing to do so either
attitude from either direction is deadly
to a marriage both are completely wrong
and you just have to wonder like I think
this is something that that we all have
to think about and if you're feeling
unappreciated in your marriage and
you're feeling like your spouse isn't
grateful for the things that you do I
think you have to stop and ask yourself
okay do I appreciate them do i express
gratitude to them is it possible that
they feel exactly like I feel is it even
possible that my own lack of
appreciation and gratitude is what
precipitated their lack of it is it
possible that they're now resentful
because of me did it really start with
me I mean these are questions in the
article she never grapples with that
question at all she never in the article
stops to wonder hey you know I I wonder
what my role in this whole thing is and
so it's no surprise that the marriage
fell apart because if if both or even
one person in a marriage is not willing
to look at themselves critically then
again that's just gonna be deadly for a
marriage
one last thing a mother is very angry
because she heard a Southwest gate agent
at the airport making fun of her
daughter's name her daughter's name is
spelled ABCDE the letters ABCDE that's
what she names her daughter
it's pronounced AB City
AB city ab city I think abs abs see the
mother Tracy Redford well she has a
normal name but she couldn't give her
daughter one the mother says the gate
agent started laughing pointing at me
and my daughter talking to the other
employees so I turned around and said
hey I can hear you and if I can hear you
my daughter can hear you so I appreciate
it if you just stop well I was sitting
there she took a picture of my boarding
pass and chose to post it on social
media mocking my daughter it was
actually brought to my attention by
somebody who had been who had seen it on
Facebook and I reported it to Southwest
Airlines Southwest hadn't done anything
yet now listen obviously it's wrong to
put it on social media and they
shouldn't be making fun of the daughter
but whose fault is it I mean what did
you think would happen you can't give
your child an insane ridiculous name and
then act surprised when people react to
it what did you think is gonna have you
give her the name ABCDE like that's it's
not possible to react to that in any
other way it would it would take immense
self-control to to read that name and
with a straight face it would be very
difficult to do so here's my message to
all parents your kid has to live with
the name that you give him at least
until he's old enough to change it which
means he's definitely gonna go through
grade school at the very least with
whatever name you hung around his neck
so do him a favor and give him a normal
name don't be selfish about it don't try
to be cute
don't worry about what's trendy just
give him a normal name he deserves a
normal name you have a normal name so
give him one um not a name that needs to
be explained not a name that will elicit
instinctive laughter from anyone who
sees it or hears it if if it is a name
that that he is going to have to explain
and justify for the rest of his life
then don't give it to him that's the
name is a curse
so don't do that now if you want to give
something a crazy name then get a pet
this is one of the only advantages of
having a pet is that you can name it
whatever you want and it doesn't matter
so get a gerbil
and you can and you can get that out of
your system that's my recommendation if
you really feel like you want to give
your kids some crazy name go get a
gerbil or a hamster instead and get it
out of your system give the name to the
gerbil or to your dog or whatever it
doesn't matter you could to name a pet
you could just mix up some Scrabble
titles so take some Scrabble tiles and
mix them up in a bag and then spill them
on the table and whatever comes out just
make that the name oh I guess we're
gonna call our dog plus new you know
whatever it doesn't matter but don't do
that to your child we named our dog
after after one of my favorite bourbon
distilleries well err we named the dog
well err it was either that or name him
after an obscure Civil War general now I
would never do that to a child that
would never name a child after bourbon
but I figure it's a dog why not so do it
to your pet give him whatever name you
want not to your child your child should
just have a normal name there are
probably about I don't know you know for
for for either gender there's probably
there's there are probably a 100 200
names that are perfectly normal and fine
so just relegate yourself to those names
and do your child a favor in the process
all right we'll leave it there thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed